it's not possible it is I don't believe
you believe it I can't believe after all
these years and finally discovering the
truth well it is true you don't like the
matrix yes I don't like the matrix oh
you're talking about the sequel is he no
the original matrix all of them I think
they're dumb movies but everybody loves
the matrix I don't I think it's
overrated I mean okay it's not horrible
or anything but when push comes to shove
I think all of them are really really
silly films but it's symbolic it means
stuff just because it's symbolic and
mean stuff doesn't automatically make it
good I mean what am I supposed to lie
about my opinion you were gonna piss off
so many people look if there's anything
big hero 6 has taught me is that even if
you think a film is OK the internet will
accept it in a fair and balanced way
decides who's gonna take it back
seriously not only here tell that you
don't like the matrix it's very
understandable mr. Alger Critic most
people have issues with the seat no I'm
not talking about the sequel's I'm
talking about all of them I just don't
like the matrix really and so what if I
don't what does it matter
I represent the fan base mr. Alex a
critic I am agent schmuck and you should
well know that everybody loves the
matrix well I'm sorry I just don't
I mean don't get me wrong its technology
and style inspired a lot in terms of
cinema for years every film was trying
to look like the matrix but even before
the crowd hating sequels came out I
still thought this was a pretentious and
silly film everyone saw it as this deep
mind-blowing experience when in truth
dozens of science fiction stories and
movies have done this idea before the
idea that our reality is an illusion
hell even some of the effects it's
famous for were being done before this
movie came out they just weren't
perfected yet it's got some clever stuff
but on the whole I just didn't think it
worked but mr. Allen to critic it's
symbolic and means stuff the film is a
masterpiece by every definition of the
word it's almost as if the writers
weren't even writing but prints crying
brilliant have you liked it recently
like in the past 10 years it's just the
teeny teeny babies David I'll tell you
what mr. Ahlers your critic why don't
you just explain why you do not like the
movies okay but only if you stop
puckering your lips like that now I make
no promises all right this is the matrix
why are you looking over there I don't
know just feels right oh we start off in
an era of film when the color green
ruled the world for some reason as
secret agents arrive at a break-in and
are so determined to convince you that
they're not secret agents nothing
actually wears sunglasses in the middle
of the night maybe the matrix is really
bright the orders were for your
protection I think we're gonna handle
one little girl big you're the more
condescending I see it the more ironic
the following scene will be the person
inside is Trinity who waits to partake
in shots that at the time we're awesome
but now it just kind of seemed weird and
pointless perhaps it was done to show
her legs will look good from any angle
which they do they do
Sharon's the captain ages through
effects that really don't hold up very
well and she's told to get to a phone as
it's her only exit to be teleported
have you ever wondered it just one time
the ringing phone wasn't an exit but
instead was just a wrong number
oh shit we think at the Keanu Reeves do
a good-looking hacker who's about to
realize all his years of staying indoors
on his computer is about to make him a
badass action hero as well as the
Messiah hey I think I'm starting to
understand this film's fan base good the
money to grant hallelujah you might say
everyman my own personal Jesus Christ
wow you just said it I mean there wasn't
any like hidden messages or symbol as a
note you just sent the film literally
spelled out that he was the Messiah
what the philosophy books have to say
about that you know all those books that
came out that was like philosophy in the
matrix ooh what is it mean Oh what did
they say at that point oh so he goes to
a club
I really wish blade would shoot up where
he meets Trinity is you on my computer
that you're in danger and that I
literally have the same reaction
throughout the entire film no really you
could impale me on metal wires and I'll
still have this face but let's not tempt
fate I know why you hardly sleep why you
live alone and why night after night
he's a dork so Trinity leaves him with
that essential big book talk when the
next day at work we see his boss tries
to clarify to us more why his rebellious
loser behavior is secretly inspired you
have a problem with authority in stanza
you believe that you're special that
somehow the rules do not apply to you
obviously you are mistaken can we just
cut to every snobby Authority fear who's
ever given this movie speech to a young
brilliant genius you have a problem with
authority he's got a real problem with
authority that somehow the rules do not
apply to you you don't necessarily think
the rules apply to you obviously you are
mistaken you will find that it is you
who are mistaken and I hope in no way
you're drumming to a different beat will
save all of mankind
I'm a bit gooey Thomas Anderson yeah
that's me
his name is Tom I mean I know he's given
himself the name neo and that's what
everybody calls him but just kind of
sucks up the epicness once you know that
doesn't it the fate of all mankind is in
the hands of a guy named Tom fucking Tom
what would Tom do all praise save your
Tom really tom yes but neo is an anagram
for one
yes but tom is also an anagram for OMT
oh my top yeah Tom in that anagram is
also an anagram for OMT oh hi Tom I'll
miss to the Tom you and I will lick with
it your testicle okay have a nice day
I will not wish you the same as I'm just
too thanks T and important to do so
so Tom gets a call from a man named
Morpheus who says agents are after it
the cubicle across from you is empty
would he know now
really let's just give this faith all
the matrix's wiring coding endless
connections all of us being hooked up
and they're fucking outwitted by a
goddamn cubicle wall
you must understand mr. Alec of credit
all the rebel fighters have been
employed but he isn't
not yet the matrix is all controlled by
machines they can become anyone and do
anything just through coding can't they
just do like a code google search for
Tom stop calling him back and find a bed
easily I mean just because he's behind a
wall doesn't mean this code still is in
there no I don't think you comprehend
how truly thick that cubicle waters
daddy way as you can see we ended up
getting him it's not like he stood out
like like the most wanted woman you've
been looking for standing right next to
you drenched in leather so loud you
could actually call her a bull's eye
even with you looking right fucking
adder where's her cubicle wall on that
one The Matrix is very glitchy so he
meets up with agent Smith played by Hugo
Weaving who's trying to find out the
location of Morpheus he is considered by
many authorities to be the most
dangerous man alive you can't scare me
with this Gestapo crap when Tom refuses
to tell them they give him the silent
treatment and put a tracking device in
something bodies intercepted later by
Trinity's gang who wants to make sure
they know where's loyalties lie right
now there's only one way
or the highway please kneel you have to
trust me
because you have been down there now you
know that road
exactly where it ends so they get the
tracking device out of him by literally
ripping it out of his stuff
families forgets to act like getting
something right now your stomach really
fucking hurts
I mean I know it should be screaming in
agony but I'm just so puzzled as to why
you haven't attended my wound yet I mean
you didn't even put a bandaid on it so
he finally meets Morpheus as he's told
what the matrix is the matrix is
everywhere it is all around us even now
in this very room you can feel it when
you go to work when you go to church if
God enlightenment the force and a slit
all rolled into one you take the blue
pill you wake up in your bed and believe
whatever you want to believe you take
the red pill you stay in Wonderland it
also relieves nighttime sniffling
sneezing coughing aching fever so you
can see past reality he's supposed to
turn to the Thom 1000 simply by touching
a mirror which is never explained but
fucking get used to that
as he's teleported to a rebirth metaphor
where one of the Machine sees him waking
up
are you my mommy
he's pushed down to where they dumped
the other people who wake up where
Morpheus in the gang are there to grab
which isn't guarded at all apparently I
mean for what the hell couldn't just
anyone hang out here to pick up
unplugged people to join their army
don't you think there be at least some
security system letting the machines
know that people are being picked up who
woke up and are probably a little pissed
off and might be starting an underground
revolution why are these things so
resistant about looking behind a wall ty
got up a hearing Toph looks funny this
is a punk switch
and psycho right tank and his big
brother dozer the little one behind you
his mouse they will be your obvious
disciples for the evening try to guess
which one is Judas I think you'll be
pleasantly surprised I know what you
think actually I have been thinking that
ever since they got here
why why didn't I take the blue pill
actually I'm colorblind and thought I
was taking the blue pill but hey what
light gives you fucking lemons right
this will feel weird
so they plug Tommy and to show him that
the matrix is apparently 90% of we're
all television ads take place this is
the world that you know ignore that past
life he's shown that the real world is
in ruin and ruled by the machines who
took over harnessing people's energy
into their power and that humanity isn't
born anymore but grown at some point in
the early 21st century all of mankind
was united in celebration we marveled at
our own magnificence as we gave birth to
a a I
you know artificial intelligence really
the one the fucking one our Savior from
this advanced technological world has to
be reminded of what a I means isn't it
like being the world's greatest frat
house and not knowing what BYOB stands
for tomorrow I have even more
long-winded speeches to make so they
teach Tom that end is mental realm of
illusion the most powerful force is
still apparently just beating the shit
out of each other
I know kung foo great now try to pick up
acting but to the credit they do still
show that mind over matter is still the
greatest weapon free and thus went the
last remaining thread of anybody ever
taking my career seriously I'm just
always gonna be summed up in that one
word thanks for chess keys
but thankfully this world operates on
toontown logic as um learns yet another
important lesson I thought it wasn't
real your mind makes it real
so my praying coughed blood but it looks
like the machines are trying to track
their ship down yeah squiddy's sweeping
in quick squiddy
I said no killing machine design for one
thing search in destroy you know I just
want to thank you for finishing my
sentence there because if you didn't I
just be like oh one thing and then like
nobody would answer it I would just look
really awkward and stupid but because of
you continued it suddenly it looked
badass it awesome so thank you so much
for making that not the least bit
pretentious
nice of you
how's a really dumb scene I know what
that is
okay schmuck how the fuck is this idiot
supposed to be the one I mean I know I
supposed to be learning and discovering
stuff but he's not given any personality
that indicates he has any leadership
skills he's not even given a personality
well mr. Allens Critic what does it
truly mean to have a personality got
like you or me or any of us any of us
can what are you doing personality but
what does it mean to be here in the now
to have does this stop in order for us
to come together to mean how are you
planning one der mr. Allen to critic
where we even all come from you feel
alone isolated we can help what was this
is agent Schmidt yeah but it's caught up
in making philosophical speeches that's
talking to me like a real person yes we
call that Dolan he'll be doing that for
a while you need to escape now schmuck
is obsessed with the matrix so he will
use matrix logic of life the purpose of
destiny the purpose of the life purpose
of destiny this is what a plant oh my
god where'd he go how the hell did he do
that he was there and now he's gone I
suppose he could be under this thin
movable surface well it's just too crazy
he's gotta be somewhere else
dear mr. a logic written here Mr Al Joe
go in the back
what the hell what the hell's going on
here the revolution has begun critic the
uprising is upon us who are you we are
people who do not like the matrix there
are others we are a small group but more
and more people are waking up the
stilted acting the pretentious dialogue
and the painfully obvious metaphors we
cannot hide from the truth any longer
allow us to introduce ourselves
I am Alchemist and this is my partner
tama D really that's what you're going
with well you wrote it okay whatever but
what am i smoke he's gonna find us back
here
not likely though I suppose he could be
hiding behind the door well that's awful
alright so tell me what do I have to do
that which is your destiny
now you understand everything as I
explained it to you not really I
couldn't understand what you're saying
over all your clothes well let me start
again by every meaning of the word just
stand still and tell me you must review
the movie and show people that it wasn't
the perfect film they thought it was huh
that's not too hard but wait who will
listen to my rambling philosophical
speeches oh I will I need a nap anyways
very good so as I was saying we needed
to get leather so our characters go into
the matrix to meet up with a character
named the Oracle who will determine
whether or not he's the one to save the
world
remember draw no attention to yourself
whatsoever good what I used to eat that
as a good news sorry that was my attempt
at acting like a human being
it failed I know he goes into a room
filled with people so advanced that they
watched giant bunnies on TV when one of
the kids teaches him a neat little trick
do not try and bend the spoon instead
only try to realize the truth what truth
there is no spoon now truth be told I
actually really like this in and think
it's one of the more brilliant metaphors
of the movie but because this is a
comedy show I'm just gonna play this
Britain's playing him again I'm excited
so he meets the orc a program who can
apparently predict the future because we
all know how that software works to her
credit though it does sort of feel like
she's evolved to a higher plane the
higher plane of actually having a
personality do you think you are the one
honestly I don't know open your mouth
say ah ah now I'm supposed to say hmm
that's interesting but another one sorry
kid
what was said was for you and for you
alone she said I wasn't the one I didn't
hear that and said you're gonna risk
your life we can't hear a thing she said
you totally shouldn't do Internet you do
it you're gonna endanger everybody into
it but Tom notices something on their
way back deja vu is usually a glitch in
the matrix it happens when they change
something so agents finally come in and
try to stop
Wow only an hour and 20 minutes in and
we finally have some gunfire if this
were monsters why we'd be wrapping up by
now yelling you're not red Brown you
don't need to announce your rage you
know if you want to preserve the image
of Morpheus there's this badass Action
Hero
you might want to consider cutting the
clip of his head slamming into a toilet
seat like a drunk college student just
saying harsh is the mysticism a bit
taken and that much has changed since
1999 it turns out there's a traitor in
there miss the angry Italian who always
plays the angry Italian if you have
anything terribly important to say the
switch I suggest you say no no please
don't not like this not like this
oh they gave so much emotion for that
character that had what two lines in the
entire film I'm sure gonna miss the way
she wore white too late
god damn you cypher you almost made me
act there I don't believe it but he's at
by one of the other crew members that
got electrocuted in the stomach because
as this movie has shown us blows to the
belly are like pets with a pillow for
some reason it's just a 20 degree burn
really I feel better if anything so they
had to save Morpheus from being bored
into submission from another one of
weaving speeches every mammal on this
planet instinctively develops a natural
equilibrium if you don't take me up on
my kissing advances I'm just gonna have
to steal the first smooch as tom and
trinity trust like those kids who always
wanted attention in high school
take that innocent security guards just
doing your job tell your wife and kids I
said fuck you but things get tricky when
tom has to go up against an agent who
he's been told nobody has ever survived
again seeing how they can dodge bullets
from any distance dodge this I don't
know who knew that apparently the secret
was giving a solid two seconds saying a
catchphrase allowing it to know exactly
where the bullet is going to go and yet
somehow forget to use that speed of
light movement to dodge it I got to give
credit I want to figure that out they
don't seem to use that speed of light
movement here either when Tom opens fire
while partaking in this Phil's favorite
pastime shell case porn oh if I could
orgasm bullets I would and because the
first Morpheus yell wasn't funny enough
we now get it in slo-mo baby
is he breaking up it's Jane's or singing
the last note of an aria
they have a pretty cool helicopter chase
with Trinity jumping off just before the
copter explode well that's cool but why
would somebody program window tidal
waves into the matrix is it kinda like
that hidden 1up there's really no rhyme
or reason why it's there or how you're
supposed to discover it but you're just
gonna benefit off of how cool it is
anyway it's hell I'll take it it's cool
yes only the one could hold on to a
woman who weighs less than him wait how
is this particularly one issue
they're not hope yet we spelled out
everything else for the audience why
stop now you I want to tell you
something
everything the Oracle told me is come
true you know let's pretend that there's
agents chasing us and can turn into
anybody in times of facts time perhaps
we should save this little chitchat for
one that's not happening for example
you're talking might take out the exact
amount of time for me to not escape
thanks bitch
so because this movie is first-half
nothing but talk in second half nothing
but fighting you be here some more
fighting empty so yeah but I meant your
head the thought occurs to me mr.
Anderson that we are far too dusty what
through the logic of Merrie Melodies he
just ends up inside the Train and the
chase continues
you ever wonder how once again they can
dodge the bullets so quickly but it's um
I'll run faster there's not like a
matrix cheat code or something like that
goodbye mr. Chu angers your reign of
mundane terror hasn't so once the
machines tried to break into their ship
Trinity in this groundbreaking
philosophical mind-blowing movie that
everybody praises literally brings it
back through the power of love oh yeah I
could totally tell by the incredible
chemistry you guys shared throughout the
entire film like that scene that scene
and that scene but hey don't hog all
that romantic staring to yourselves
save some for Edward of Bella so Tom
comes back to life because Jesus and
finally takes out Agent Smith
whoa I'm becoming blander more wood on
interest and have a son interest to ruin
the Davey Earth Stood Still draught even
boil by the power of love so just to
clarify this revolutionary
groundbreaking movie that everyone was
just blown away by how different it was
has the white guy singing the black guy
cry symbolism or obvious the Man of
Steel and a woman saving the man not
through physical strength but for
emotional support
well apart from every single movie I've
ever seen in my life that is very
original stuff so Tom leaves a message
to the Machine saying that the
revolution is on and the uprising will
begin that is he sounds so disinterested
I'm not sure if he's saying it or
reading it off cue guys I'm going to
hang up this phone and then I'm going to
show these people which you don't want
them to see a world without rules and
controls Without Borders great yeah okay
great anything is possible
thus he ascends into the credits and the
movie finally wraps up so that was the
matrix and is it really the masterpiece
everybody's saying it is don't get me
wrong there's a lot of cool scenes and
some very clever analogies but there's
also a ton of stuff that doesn't make
sense which would be fine if the
characters were more fun and distracted
us from that but the leads are just so
wooden it everyone else takes this
material way too seriously almost like
the writers think they're paving the way
for some sort of new religion or
philosophy I don't never when this film
came out everybody was saying this was
the new Star Wars like really tom and
trinity have the same chemistry as han
and leia the look and style is timeless
that'll never age year after year
something's not right here some symbols
work and even the initial idea isn't
that bad but the only game changer is
its technology and even that at times is
starting to look really David I don't
hate this movie if anything I do
appreciate what impact gets had on
action films to be visual and even an
intellectual medium but as a film I just
don't think it holds up not the worst
but definitely David and besides there
is one major plot hole that everybody
seems to ignore and what plot hole is
that mr. Alger crit Kent my letter will
allow me to the super sword dammit I
can't my leather be tight and won't let
me with my gun it seems you're out of
ideas mister alg quick re schmuck I'll
accept defeat as long as you answer one
major plot hole about the matrix
I'm oh I browse mr. Elric ribbit why do
we need the matrix because it's a
masterpiece
a great masterpiece is there another
kind but now I'm not talking about
matrix the movie I'm talking about
matrix the idea the idea inside the
movie if the computers feed off of
people's energy while they're asleep
then why create the matrix at all why
not just let them dream or make them
brand a lobotomize zoom or something
The Matrix is a form of product we
needed it always you said you said the
matrix as a master best core I said of
great masterpieces or any of our whole
review back for you at play I know what
I said I don't have to have a play back
to me lion soldiers sometimes writers
take matters into their own Hey
no smoke a moment ago you said writers
never take matters into their own hands
so the matrix should even be around
should I don't even know what movie were
satirizing anymore just say you can't
handle the truth is that what we're
doing hello why is there a matrix it's
impossible they could've cooked dinner
why is there a matrix the whole purpose
of the movie they could've overlooked
something so why is there
I'll just blow up in a stupid effect I
know you're out there people who don't
like the matrix I'm going to hang up
this phone and show you a world where
you don't need to love what everyone
else loves or hate what everyone else
aids a world without a loop a world
without pressure
a world without we're leather pandering
to a very specific demographic and
seriously what what is on them
where we go from there is up to you
hey guys
I mean artificial intelligence